i want to i want to pull this storage i
think it's a good opportunity to talk
about gensake we have this from the
independent
saki defends bidens against claims they
broke mask mandate on dinner date zeki
battles conservative reporter over
president's mask usage there's so much
here i love conservative reporter that's
that's uh
peter ducey right yeah so what okay did
peter do he come up and say that he was
pro-life and had a question did he say
uh jen i'm pro-life and i want small
government and lower taxes now my
question is why is he a conservative
reporter but would that not to mention
you would never frame any of those folks
from nbc or new york times as liberal
reporters not even the msnbc but also
who cares
he asked her a simple question about
their policies
why does this background have anything
to do with it
it's i mean the labels but again because
this goes back to what we were just
talking about because if you if you
demean
the reporter who's asking it then
there's less likely that you'll believe
the answer or the predicate of you know
so the it's it's how to add hobbies
right wing is bad conservative bad now
the funny thing is as the saying goes
liberals think conservatives are evil
conservatives think liberals are
misguided right i think people who are
moderate libertarian you know what
i think it's easier just to name the
cult the democratic establishment and
their voters are an occult because
everyone else they disagree with each
other a lot of things luke's fairly
libertarian or very freedom oriented but
there are conservatives who disagree but
they agree on the truth and the facts to
a great deal
but there are a lot of people who
blindly follow behind genseki i think
it's interesting for two reasons the fir
well three first is pointing out saying
a conservative reporter i find kind of
funny but then you've got joe biden
violating his own mask role yep gen saki
defending breaking his own rule and
not a single reporter actually
questioning outside of ducey who is then
ignored or smeared
where are the journalists now i think
it's interesting because you had this
job
yes when you had this job you were not
given any free passes in fact i think it
was kind of brutal right the journalists
were just always just coming at you with
very pointed very hard or even misframed
questions
yeah i mean i i
mentioned you guys before we started i
did a there was a profile and jen and a
reporter from new york times called me
and they said well what do you think and
i said look the reality is i walked into
the lion's den every day and she walks
into a bunch of kittens and everyone
thought that was ridiculous how could i
say but the reality is i mean just look
at the video when i walked in you had
acosta jumping up and down like a hyena
and and all these people are like
you know i'm gonna but when she walks in
it's like you know a bunch of
well-trained third graders they sit
there with their hands on their lap and
politely raise their hand and then you
have a guy like ducey who literally just
asks a simple question and they go well
that's the right-wing guy what was was
ducey there when you were uh he wasn't
no did you he was at fox but john
roberts primarily was there kevin cork
was there
from fox and then um
i'm trying to remember um
come to me but there was one other
woman who worked and she's now left fox
but are there a lot of the same
reporters that were there when you were
no um not there's some but generally a
lot of them switch over
it's a tough beat so i think a lot of
times when there's a switch of
administration the folks who were say
covering biden on the campaign trail
will kind of tap in if you will to cover
the white house because they know the
candidate or it's their turn and i think
frankly there's a lot of burnout after
you've been living especially
covering donald trump where you have to
be up early and stay up late just to
stay up with the guys like five days a
week oh no it's a seven a week yeah yeah
twenty four seven yeah you can be off
some days but it's like you would do
like seven days in a row of speaking
every day oh i was so the way i worked
for my tenure was on sundays i would try
not to go into the office but i was
still
you know either on my computer or on an
iphone or what have you all day long but
saturdays i was in and you know every
weekday i don't i don't want to blame
jen saki there was a big you know when
she came in and the circle back stuff
and the memes i think they're funny
circle back i'll circle back come on
dear job
but i'm not gonna blame a person who's
hired to be a spokesperson i mean
we get it when when when the deepwater
horizon thing happens in the gulf of
mexico do we expect bp to come out and
be like we are irresponsible and we
cause the major oil spill it's our fault
that's what i didn't maybe not expect
isn't the right word
look a prosecutor that walks out and
says look i know my boss just said this
but they're nuts
like you got about eight seconds before
they're like can we take your badge and
get out that's just not how it works
you're like a lawyer and i hate to use
the analogy but it's easy to make that
you don't get up there you make the best
case for the person you represent that's
it plain simple you're not there to
interpret for them i would say sales rep
is a better kind of description from my
own personal opinion you're selling
policies that again you can't really
answer for them
i think that's probably more you don't
go you know to be honest with you after
about three weeks the product sucks
so but but these are sales people and
people need to understand like the word
of the government is not gospel it's
sales it's trying to convince you of a
certain idea this is why i went when
like i said when seki came in and
conservatives were coming at her i'm
like i i don't care but you know what i
really care about is the journalists who
have decided to lay down their swords
they're no longer adversarial and you
can argue but they ask your tough no
they don't ask her
she says i'll circle back and we never
hear anything she's not being challenged
on that the only one who's doing
anything is ducey and his questions
typically are fairly good normal
questions they're respectful but the
media attacks him but by the way just so
we're clear just so we're clear
she chooses not to call on anybody else
that's the token right and so peter
becomes the one person that she calls it
there's 30 other people we have a white
house correspondent too actually that
switch in and out from newsmax in there
they don't get questions neither do
anyone else that's right leaning she
calls on all the mainstream guys and
then throws the obligatory token
question to peter so that she can say
that she sent one over but nobody else
in that briefing room gets one i took
questions from literally every single
person in there not only that
but when i started i actually did this i
killed the tradition of starting with
the ap and working through the
mainstream media backwards i started in
the back of the room and moved forward
wow because to me that was that was very
symbolic of what trump was all about and
so i thought all right how better to
show this than not by calling on them
didn't you guys do that skype thing we
did yeah so i brought in um
reporters that couldn't make it to the
brief room but part of the reason was to
allow issues that weren't coming up it's
it's all these guys are group think so
if cnn asked a question then the
washington post would say you know
following up on that well what i wanted
to know what was going on in cleveland
in providence rhode island and you know
seattle so that you could hear an issue
that was affecting real people in their
communities about some federal land
policy or a school you know an education
policy issue but
all that i ever got was russia russia
russia so i figured you know what i have
a feeling that people out in america
don't necessarily all care about this i
don't you know
whether it's you or saki
i see a white house press secretary like
like saying it's it's they're there to
sell the policy they're there to speak
to to not interpret i guess but you know
to present this but you got to remember
the other thing is jen was at cnn prior
to coming here these are her colleagues
they're her buddies do you think they're
going to attack her
like
she's going back there just
let's be fair they could have pulled a
homeless guy off the street put him in
there and as right fair enough
but but let's be honest i mean i agree
with you it literally you could put
anyone up there every day and it won't
significantly change i love the biden's
fake question like you know remember
when that journalist came up to ask a
question but they asked something
different he was like i thought you were
going to ask about uh whatever but
pelosi think about this we showed this
in our show today pelosi stood in front
of the press
and was asked last week about the the
build back better plan and she said you
folks need to do a better job of selling
it yes that was like amazing oh my god
you said the quiet part out loud
you literally chided them for not doing
your job but that's what they think
that's what the left thinks is that the
press is a tool to get out of our
message i mean how else did biden get
elected biden literally hid in the
basement while the media did the
pitching the campaigning for what i've
got you know just it's it's like
weakened at bernie's man right shameless
plug i have two chapters in my new book
that just talk about the what the press
doesn't do
right yeah there's radical names radical
nation but i have two chapters in here
that talk about the complicit nature of
the press and it's the thing that people
have to understand is when you look at
the examples
of how biden conducts themselves and how
the press doesn't do their job
then you get it how deep do you go on
the rabbit hole of who owns the
companies that run the media it's a
great question i in this book that's not
i i touch on that in my last book but
i'm not i'm not selling that what's that
one called leading america but but
because i think that's a good point but
i but here the point was to look at the
buy administration and recognize the
fact that they weren't getting the and
we talked about this from the you talk
about the mass mandate now him going to
this georgetown restaurant that's how he
started remember the fact that this was
one of the first questions that she got
asked by ducey when he went to the
lincoln memorial he doesn't wear a mask
and she comes back and it's like well
come on same same answer by the way no
big deal before the before the show you
know i'm like oh sean you have a book
what's it called a radical nation joe
biden and kamala harris's dangerous plan
for america and i was like just hold it
up during every segment
is it even their plan or someone
deciding all this stuff behind the
scenes well look the one thing that i'll
tell you is
biden during the campaign said i'm going
to be the most progressive president
ever and i frankly think that most
people dismissed him on the right and
the left he does understand this he's
going to have one term and he wants a
legacy that says i did more for the left
than anybody else i want to be
remembered for the guy
who named the first black female vice
president the first openly gay
department head which is what he says
even though rick cornell did serve under
trump but he wants to nuance it to say
department but all of these things that
he wants to do are to cement his legacy
as the latest version of fdr
a bunch of virtues the only issue is
he's just you know not there he's not
he's like 13
i have a different understanding of it
to be honest with you i i think he's a
shallow man i think special interests
are using him to push through some of
the most absurd ridiculous most craziest
policies that would they would never
have the balls to do if there was a real
candidate behind that presidency two
fridays ago at a press conference he
said this if we pass my 1.2 and 3.5
legislation pieces of legislation
trillion dollars we will we will
transform the structure and nature of
our economy he knows what he's doing
so but first of all who wanted him to do
that if you know nobody if he knows what
he's doing he's tanking the economy on
purpose especially with his uh vaccine
mandates especially with his
restrictions on trade especially with
the effects that he has had on global
trade in general so i think if he knows
what he's doing he's he's
assertedly making sure that the united
states gets destroyed from the inside
especially with afghanistan policy
especially with all the policies that he
has proposed never help out the average
american let me ask you a question look
at afghanistan objectively no matter who
you are whether you've served a day in
your life or not and say to yourself
did anybody
honestly think that that was a good idea
of saying hey let's get these guys
out first and then worry about everybody
else i mean the entire thing it
literally took a sixth grader to go ah
bad idea yeah right keep your air force
the idea of look at this weekend what we
need to do is tell people to work 24 7
at the ports really you're not no one's
working to begin with and you think the
answer is to tell them to work more
meanwhile there's still crazy carbon
emissions especially passed by
california that prevent many of these
ships many of these trucks from even
operating in the state of california so
there's many layers to this that we
don't even understand yet and there's
still a truck driver shortage yeah so
being like we're opening the ports 24 7
does literally not correct and you have
to be vaccinated to make sure that you
work now but look it's here's the thing
it's got to be you told people not to
work so they didn't make things then
they couldn't ship them then they
couldn't unload them then they couldn't
stock the shelves with them and now you
go you know what the answer is just turn
it on 24 7. this is i mean work more
again you had marty walsh the secretary
of labor get asked last sunday night
what the problem was he said i don't
know if you don't know what the problem
is then you shouldn't be the secretary
of labor you have pete budergich
literally on sunday calling it a success
a success
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you